Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I thought Columbus was the hero of America. No, see, it's these Indians and the commies. They want to paint Columbus as a slave trader instead of an explorer. You've got to admit, they did get massacred, the Indians. Hey, it's not like we didn't give them stuff to make up for it. That Dominic Sandbrook was dialogue from The Sopranos, the everyday tale of New Jersey
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要每周获取独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先看，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我以为哥伦布是美国的英雄。不，你看，是这些印第安人和共产党人。他们想把哥伦布粉饰成一个奴隶贩子，而不是探险家。你不得不承认，印第安人确实被大屠杀过。嘿，又不是我们没有给他们东西来弥补。多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，那是来自《黑道家族》（新泽西黑帮日常故事）的台词。
mobsters. And I imagine any new American listeners joining us will be astonished to discover that actually I'm not from New Jersey. I'm British. They will be astonished, Tom. So that wasn't actually the authentic, genuine dialogue from The Sopranos. That was you doing that. That was me. You astound me. The accent was uncannily accurate. And I genuinely thought there were different people in the room then. It was unbelievable. Although, of course, so three of them were American. Ralphie, Christopher, and Silvio, people familiar with the Sopranos will recognize them opening guy furio he is actually from naples and he goes on to complain that he doesn't actually like columbus because columbus came from
我想任何新加入的美国听众听到这里都会大吃一惊，事实上我不是新泽西人。我是英国人。他们会大吃一惊的，汤姆。所以那其实并不是《黑道家族》中地道、真正的台词。那是你模仿的。那是我。你让我大吃一惊。那个口音简直出奇地准。我当时真的以为房间里有不同的人呢。真是难以置信。当然，其中有三个人确实是美国人。雷菲、克里斯托弗和西尔维奥，熟悉《黑道家族》的人会认出他们，而开场那个叫弗里奥的家伙，他其实来自那不勒斯，他接着抱怨说他其实不喜欢哥伦布，因为哥伦布来自
genoa he did indeed people in the north of italy he complains they're always doing down people from naples so a good way in i think to today's subject which is christopher columbus because it reminds us that columbus is a very controversial figure these days. I mean, he's arguably one of the most controversial characters in all history right now, because of course, statues of Columbus have been taken down across America. Columbus Day, which is an American federal holiday, remains enormously controversial. Some cities and some states don't even mark it.
热那亚，他确实是。意大利北部的人，他抱怨说他们总是在贬低那不勒斯人。所以我想，这是一个很好的切入点，进入我们今天的主题——克里斯托弗·哥伦布，因为这提醒我们，如今哥伦布是一个极具争议的人物。我的意思是，他可以说是整个历史中争议最大的人物之一，因为当然，全美国都在拆除哥伦布的雕像。哥伦布日作为一个美国联邦假日，依然充满巨大的争议。有些城市甚至有些州根本不庆祝它。
We'll be talking about that towards the end of this discussion, won't we? When we've dealt with Columbus, the historical figure, we'll talk about his legacy. But you're right, because Columbus, the historical figure, has now become completely bound up, hasn't he, with discussions about colonialism, empire, Eurocentrism, Western imperialism, all this sort of stuff. And Columbus has become this sort of avatar for all these things. And actually, to some degree, I would say the real sort of historical character of Christopher Columbus has been lost, don't you think? Firstly, he never actually made fall on what is today the United States. So that's very odd, for starters. And also, of course course to what extent should he be held responsible
我们会在这次讨论的尾声谈到这一点，对吧？当我们谈完哥伦布这位历史人物后，我们会探讨他的遗产。但你说得对，因为作为历史人物的哥伦布，现在已经完全与殖民主义、帝国主义、欧洲中心主义、西方帝国主义等所有这些讨论捆绑在一起了，不是吗？哥伦布已经成为所有这些事情的某种化身。事实上，在某种程度上，我认为克里斯托弗·哥伦布真正的历史角色已经迷失了，你不觉得吗？首先，他实际上从未踏上过今天的美国领土。所以，首先这就非常奇怪。而且，当然，他应该在多大程度上承担责任
for everything that happened in the wake of his discovery of the new world and even of course saying to what extent did he discover the new world so these are all very live issues but if we go back to that sentiment expressed by furo in the passage from sopranos i say brilliantly recreated kicking things off i mean he's italian but more specifically he is from Sopranos that I say brilliantly recreated. Taking things off, I mean, he's Italian, but more specifically, he is from Genoa. Yes. Is that not right? It is right. So there's no Italy at the point when Columbus was born.
对于他在发现新大陆之后发生的一切，甚至当然，他在多大程度上可以说发现了新大陆？所以这些都是非常现实的问题。但如果我们回到《黑道家族》片段中弗里奥所表达的那种情绪——我说这是精彩的重现，开个好头——我的意思是，他是意大利人，但更具体地说，他来自...等等，我说那是精彩的重现。切入正题，我的意思是，他是意大利人，但更具体地说，他来自热那亚。是的。难道不是吗？是的。所以哥伦布出生的时候并没有意大利这个国家。
I mean, Italy exists as a geographical expression, but there's obviously no united Italy. Actually, funnily enough with Columbus, there have been all kinds of theories about where he came from, because of course, his explorations were done in the name of another kind of country that didn't really quite exist at the time, Spain. So they were really done in the name of Castile. Because he wasn't Spanish, there's always been a slight hint of mystery about his origins because he wasn't Castilian, I should say. So there have been some people, for example, who've argued that actually he was a Sephardic Jew. So Simon Wiesenthal, the Nazi hunter, had this very complicated theory that Columbus's origins were actually Jewish, and he was trying to cover it up. And there'd been all kinds of sort of strange theories that he might be Catalan or Mallorcan.
我的意思是，意大利作为一个地理概念是存在的，但显然没有一个统一的意大利。事实上，有趣的是，关于哥伦布的出生地有各种各样的理论，因为当然，他的探险是以另一个在当时并不完全存在的国家的名义进行的，那就是西班牙。所以他们实际上是以卡斯蒂利亚的名义进行的。因为他不是西班牙人，他的身世一直带着一丝神秘色彩，或者我应该说，因为他不是卡斯蒂利亚人。所以有些人，比如，认为他其实是个塞法迪犹太人。因此，纳粹猎人西蒙·维森塔尔有一个非常复杂的理论，认为哥伦布的血统实际上是犹太人，而他一直在试图掩盖这一点。并且有各种各样奇怪的理论，认为他可能是加泰罗尼亚人或马洛卡人。
But most historians agree with you that he's from Genoa in the north of Italy. Glad to hear that. Well, there is a theory. When I went to Calvi in Corsica, there's a monument there to Columbus claiming that it's his birthplace. There's a little ship coming out of a wall. The Corsicans are not content with Napoleon. They want Columbus as well. And the fact that there is absolutely no evidence for this. That's often the most damning evidence of all, Tom. Well, the Corsicans say that this is because the Genoese came over and destroyed all the evidence. Oh, Tom. Well, the courts can say that this is because the Genoese came over and destroyed all the evidence. Oh, right. So, a classic conspiracy theory. But it's interesting, actually, you mentioned Napoleon. I mean, there's a kind of, perhaps a slight comparison there, because both of them come from kind of poverty-stricken backgrounds,
但大多数历史学家都同意你的看法，即他来自意大利北部的热那亚。很高兴听到这个。嗯，有一个理论。当我去科西嘉岛的卡尔维时，那里有一个纪念哥伦布的纪念碑，声称那是他的出生地。墙上伸出一艘小船。科西嘉人不满足于拿破仑。他们连哥伦布也想要。然而事实是，对此根本没有任何证据。汤姆，这往往是最致命的证据。嗯，科西嘉人说这是因为热那亚人过来摧毁了所有证据。哦，汤姆。嗯，科西嘉人说这是因为热那亚人过来摧毁了所有证据。哦，原来如此。所以，这是一个典型的阴谋论。但很有趣的是，你提到了拿破仑。我的意思是，这其中或许有一种轻微的对比，因为他们都出身于赤贫背景，
and they end up becoming perhaps some of the most famous people in the whole of history. Yes. Both of them have an Italian background, and both of them come to be associated with more powerful countries. That's right, actually. I hadn't thought of that, but they're exactly... Both end up founding dynasties. I mean, kind of an amazing... And they found dynasties, and also they become absolute templates for kind of great man history.
最后却成为了整个历史上最著名的人物。是的。他们俩都有意大利背景，而且后来都与更强大的国家联系在一起。确实如此，其实。我之前没想到这一点，但他们完全……两者最终都建立了王朝。我的意思是，这真是一种惊人的……他们建立了王朝，而且他们还成为了“伟大人物历史”的绝对样板。
The idea that an individual character who feels himself blessed by destiny can change the course of human affairs. And as we'll see with Columbus, that's actually not really quite right. Isn't one of the reasons why there is potentially this kind of mystery around Columbus's origins is that actually he was embarrassed about them. Yes, exactly. That the desire to elevate himself, to gain nobility, to bury the kind of the shame as he
那种认为一个感到自己受命运庇佑的个人角色可以改变人类历史进程的想法。正如我们接下来会看到的，这其实并不完全正确。围绕哥伦布的身世之所以可能存在这种神秘感，原因之一难道不是因为他其实对自己的出身感到难堪吗？是的，完全正确。那种想要提升自己、获得贵族身份、埋葬他所认为的卑微出身的耻辱感的渴望，
saw it of his humble origins was kind of what drove him i mean it's what made him the obsessive man he was columbus is driven throughout his entire career by this obsessive desire for status and for sort of social advancement and it's such a long and rich and complicated story the story of christopher columbus but absolutely at the heart of it is columbus's desire it's not actually so much for gold or for wealth it's for titles for status for rank but yeah for social respectability so he probably does come from from genoa his father was called domenico his mother susanna they were probably weavers from the hills above genoa so genoa for those people who don't know port in the in the north of Italy, the people there, Columbus probably spoke Ligurian, which is a Genoese dialect. So not
正是驱使他的动力。我的意思是，这正是造就了他这种偏执性格的原因。哥伦布在其整个职业生涯中，一直被这种对地位和社会晋升的偏执渴望所驱使。克里斯托弗·哥伦布的故事是一个漫长、丰富而复杂的故事，但核心绝对是哥伦布的渴望——其实与其说是为了黄金或财富，不如说是为了头衔、地位、阶级，以及对社会尊重的渴望。所以他很可能来自热那亚，他的父亲叫多米尼ко（多米尼克），母亲叫苏珊娜，他们很可能是热那亚山区的织工。所以对于那些不知道的人来说，热那亚是意大利北部的一个港口，那里的居民……哥伦布说的很可能是利古里亚语，这是一种热那亚方言。所以绝不是
classical kind of Italian by any means. It's true that Genoa today, we would think of it as quite peripheral. But Genoa is part of this. I mean, it's hugely important in this story. So there is a kind of a Spanish dimension to the story, a Portuguese dimension, and a Genoese dimension. Genoa is at the center of this huge network of trade and production and entrepreneurship. There are about 50 or so big families that trade all over, not just the Mediterranean, actually. They go all the way up to the black sea to crimea it's a body catapulted into the genoese outpost in crimea that is said to have initiated the black death isn't it that's right yes yeah exactly so so that it's along those those networks that the bubonic play travels a century or two before before columbus is is born so the Genoese had initially a lot of their interest
古典意义上的意大利语。的确，今天我们会认为热那亚相当边缘化。但热那亚是这个体系的一部分。我的意思是，它在这个故事中极其重要。所以这个故事中有一种西班牙维度、葡萄牙维度和热那亚维度。热那亚处于这个巨大的贸易、生产和创业网络中心。大约有50个左右的大家族到处做生意，不仅在地中海，事实上，他们一直走到黑海的克里米亚。据说正是投掷到热那亚克里米亚前哨站的一具投石机引发了黑死病，不是吗？正是如此，是的，完全没错。所以腺鼠疫就是沿着这些网络传播的，在哥伦布出生前一两个世纪。
had been in the East. So in Constantinople, in Crimea, as we were just talking about, but with the sort of Ottoman Turkish advances throughout the 15th century, the Genoese are now looking much more to the West. So they establish, I mean, to think of the Genoese, they're almost more of a sort of, they're not so much a nation as they are a sort of giant collection of different entrepreneurs and companies. Dominic, you mentioned this idea that he was Jewish. There's a way in which the role played by the Genoese in all these kind of various kingdoms and great cities is a bit like the Jews. Or the Armenians. Or the Armenians. Or the Armenians. Yes.
所以热那亚人最初的很多利益都在东方。比如在君士坦丁堡，在克里米亚，就像我们刚刚讨论的那样。但随着15世纪奥斯曼土耳其人的不断推进，热那亚人现在更多地将目光投向了西方。所以他们建立——如果要形容热那亚人，他们几乎更像是一个……与其说他们是一个国家，不如说他们是由不同企业家和公司组成的庞大集合体。多米尼克，你提到了他可能是犹太人这个观点。热那亚人在所有这些不同的王国和伟大城市中所扮演的角色，在某种程度上有点像犹太人。或者亚美尼亚人。或者亚美尼亚人。或者亚美尼亚人。是的。
They're very accomplished at settling in other people's kingdoms. Yes. And kind of getting protection. But they kind of retain their Genoese identity. Yeah, I think you're absolutely right. So by the second half of the 15th century, the Genoese were brilliant sailors, great entrepreneurs, great merchants and traders and all of these things. They've become established in the courts of Castile and Portugal, the two preeminent powers
他们在别人的王国里定居的本领非常高超。是的。并且能得到保护。但他们又保留了热那亚人的身份。是的，我觉得你完全说对了。所以在15世纪下半叶，热那亚人是出色的水手、伟大的企业家、伟大的商人和贸易商，集各种身份于一身。他们在伊比利亚半岛的两个主要强国——卡斯蒂利亚和葡萄牙的宫廷中站稳了脚跟。
in the Iberian Peninsula. So they have their own court in Seville, for example. The Centurioni family, the Centurion in Spanish, they become very important to Columbus. They're established in Malaga. There's another family very important to Columbus, the Pinelli family. They have become established. They're working in the Canary Islands, which we will be talking about quite a lot. Actually, the Canary Islands are part of the sort of Genoese expansion story. So the Canary Islands, Madeira, the Azores, the Cape Verde Islands, these are all in the Atlantic.
例如，他们在塞维利亚有自己的宫廷。森图里奥尼家族（西班牙语中的森图里奥）对哥伦布变得非常重要。他们在马拉加站稳了脚跟。另一个对哥伦布非常重要的家族是皮内利家族。他们也已经站稳了脚跟。他们在加那利群岛工作，我们接下来会经常谈到加那利群岛。事实上，加那利群岛是热那亚扩张故事的一部分。所以加那利群岛、马德拉群岛、亚速尔群岛、佛得角群岛，这些都在大西洋上。
And the idea that Columbus comes out of nowhere and, in inverted commas, discovers America, and this is the first time Europeans have ever known there's anything to the west, is just not right. Because the Europeans in the 15th century are expanding all the time into the Atlantic. So those islands that I've mentioned, some of them hundreds of miles from the coast of Spain and Portugal. Spain and Portugal have taken those islands, and actually the Genoese have been in the forefront of that. So it's the Genoese who discovered the Canary Islands, or rediscovered them, I should say, in 1330. It's another Genoese, a guy called Uzu Damari,
那种认为哥伦布凭空出现，然后加上引号“发现了美洲”，并且这是欧洲人第一次知道西方有任何东西的观点，是完全错误的。因为15世纪的欧洲人一直在向大西洋扩张。所以我刚才提到的那些岛屿，有些距离西班牙和葡萄牙海岸数百英里。西班牙和葡萄牙已经占领了这些岛屿，事实上热那亚人一直冲在最前面。所以是热那亚人发现了加那利群岛，或者说我应该纠正一下，是在1330年重新发现了它们。另一个热那亚人，一个叫乌祖·达马里的家伙，
who's the first sailing for the Portuguese. He's the first European to sail up the rivers Senegal and Gambia. Another Genoese, Antonio Nolli, is the first to establish, for the Portuguese, a settlement in the Cape Verde Islands. And the Genoese in all of this, one of the things they are doing and that Columbus definitely does not invent is they are trading slaves. The Mediterranean is this great slave trading network and the Genoese are at the forefront of that. And Dominic, is that because while they were in the East, they could trade in all the
是第一个为葡萄牙人航行的人。他是第一个沿塞内加尔河和冈比亚河逆流而上的欧洲人。另一个热那亚人安东尼奥·诺利，是第一个为葡萄牙人在佛得角群岛建立定居点的人。在所有这一切中，热那亚人正在做的事情之一——这也是哥伦布绝对没有发明的——就是他们在贩卖奴隶。地中海是一个巨大的奴隶贸易网络，而热那亚人正处于这个网络的最前沿。多米尼克，这是不是因为当他们在东方时，他们可以交易东方的所有
riches of the East, the spices and so on. Once that starts to get closed off to them, what else is there for them to trade except for slaves? The West is much less advanced. There's much less natural resources than you would get, say, from the Indies. Well, they're trading olive oil. They're trading some sugar. So they are trading, I think, some commodities, but slaves are very lucrative. There are an awful lot of slaves in Portugal and in Spain. But they're domestic slaves, aren't they? So they're not yet establishing plantations or anything like that. Right. So they're not working on plantations in Spain and Portugal. I mean, we'll perhaps touch on this again a little bit later, but if you were a sort of Spanish bigwig,
财富，比如香料等等？一旦那条路开始对他们关闭，除了奴隶，他们还有什么可交易的呢？西方远不如东方先进。那里没有像你在印度能获得的那么多自然资源。好吧，他们在交易橄榄油。他们在交易一些糖。所以我想他们确实在交易一些商品，但奴隶非常利润丰厚。葡萄牙和西班牙有大量的奴隶。但他们是家奴，对吧？所以他们当时还没有建立种植园之类的东西。没错。所以他们没有在西班牙和葡萄牙的种植园里劳作。我的意思是，我们稍后可能会再次触及这一点，但如果你是一个西班牙大人物，
or indeed a Spanish, you know, part of the sort of professional or middle classes, entrepreneurial classes, let's say, a merchant or something or a clerk or whatever, it's quite likely that you would have one or two slaves. And a lot of those slaves are Berbers from North Africa. Some of them are black slaves brought by the Portuguese from the west coast of Africa, but probably the majority are Eastern European. Well, so hence their Slavs. Yes, Slavs.
或者确实是一个西班牙的专业阶层或中产阶层、创业阶层的一部分，比方说商人、职员什么的，你很有可能会有一两个奴隶。其中许多奴隶是来自北非的柏柏尔人。有些是葡萄牙人从西非海岸带来的黑奴，但可能大多数是东欧人。好吧，所以因此他们被称为“Slavs”（斯拉夫人/奴隶）。是的，斯拉夫人。
So they, and that's a practice that obviously has been carried to its kind of peak in the Ottoman Empire. So in the Ottoman Empire, they have loads and loads of slaves and lots of Eastern European slaves. And the Genoese have been part of that business, you know, across the sort of Black Sea and their Mediterranean slave trading. So that's the world that Columbus is born into. Yes. So as someone who is poor, but ambitious, he's not educated.
所以他们，这种做法显然在奥斯曼帝国被推向了巅峰。所以在奥斯曼帝国，他们有数不清的奴隶和大量的东欧奴隶。热那亚人一直参与其中，你知道的，跨越黑海和他们地中海的奴隶贸易。这就是哥伦布出生的世界。是的。所以作为一个贫穷但有雄心的人，他没有受过教育。
I mean, he will, you know, he's an autodidact. He will come to have read a lot. But to begin with, you know, he doesn't have a career in the church, doesn't beckon. No. So he could become a soldier. Yeah. But it's more obvious if you are Genoese to become a sailor. Absolutely. And so he goes to sea very young and he kind of absorbs that familiarity with
我的意思是，他会，你知道的，他是自学成才的。他后来读了很多书。但一开始，你知道，他没有走上教会的道路，教会并没有向他招手。不。所以他可以成为一名士兵。是的。但如果你是热那亚人，成为一名水手会更显而易见。绝对的。所以他很年轻就出海了，他吸收了那种对
winds and rope and all that stuff that I know absolutely nothing about, but which if you're a young Genoese sailor, you know all about it. Yeah, absolutely. I think there's some talk later on that he might've studied at the University of Pavia, but I think a lot of biographers don't think he did. His son claims that he did, but probably that's part of that sort of burnishing of his legend. As you said, he's an autodidact, and we'll touch on that a little bit in a second. He probably goes to sea when he's in his mid-teens, maybe 14, possibly later. Where does he go? We know he goes to Tunis. We know he goes to the Genoese have colony on the Greek island of Chios, which is off the coast of modern day Turkey. But he ends up in Portugal.
风向、缆绳以及所有那些我一无所知、但如果你是一个年轻的热那亚水手就了如指掌的事物的熟悉感。是的，绝对的。我想后来有传言说他可能在帕维亚大学学习过，但很多传记作家认为他没有。他的儿子声称他读过，但这可能只是为了给他传奇色彩镀金的一部分。正如你所说，他是自学成才的，我们稍后会简要提到这一点。他可能在十几岁中期出海，大约14岁，或者可能更晚。他去了哪里？我们知道他去了突尼斯。我们知道他去了热那亚人在希腊奇奥斯岛上的殖民地，该岛位于现代土耳其海岸附近。但他最终去了葡萄牙。
That's a very well-worn route for Genoese mariners. So he's working for one of these big Genoese firms, the one I mentioned earlier, the Centurioni family. I mean, actually, your Soprano is opening. You know, the idea of these families that are really important. A family is a commercial enterprise, and Columbus knows some of the most important families. So the Portuguese have established plantations in Madeira, and they are already employing black African slaves in Madeira. So again, the idea that Columbus is the guy, as people sometimes say, he's the guy who institutes the practice of bringing black
这对热那亚水手来说是一条轻车熟路的路线。所以他为这些大型热那亚公司之一工作，也就是我刚才提到的森图里奥尼家族。我的意思是，实际上，你的《黑道家族》开场白。你知道，这些家族非常重要的概念。一个家族就是一家商业企业，而哥伦布认识一些最重要的家族。葡萄牙人在马德拉群岛建立了种植园，并且他们已经在马德拉群岛雇用黑人非洲奴隶了。所以同样，认为哥伦布是那个——正如人们有时所说的那样——率先将黑人非洲奴隶跨大西洋带到种植园劳作的人的这种观点，其实葡萄牙人已经在做了。
African slaves across the Atlantic to work in plantations. The Portuguese are actually already doing it. And he probably would have seen that when he went to Madeira. And so Dominic, presumably to begin with, his sailing has been done within the Mediterranean. So inside the Straits of Gibraltar. But now Portugal is an Atlantic facing power. So he is starting to become familiar with the winds, the currents, all that malarkey of the Atlantic. Am I right that he sails both very far south and very far north? So he sails all the way to the kind of the Gold Coast of Guinea and all that kind of stuff in the south. And then he does this extraordinary voyage. He visits Bristol. He goes to Galway in Ireland. And he goes all the way to Iceland. That's absolutely right, Tom. So he definitely
他去马德拉时很可能就已经看到了这一点。所以，多米尼克，大概一开始，他的航行都是在地中海内进行的？也就是直布罗陀海峡以内。但现在葡萄牙是一个面向大西洋的国家。所以他开始熟悉大西洋的风向、洋流和那些杂七杂八的东西。我没记错的话，他既航行得非常靠南，又航行得非常靠北？所以他一路航行到几内亚的黄金海岸之类南方的地带。然后他进行了一次非凡的航行。他访问了布里斯托尔。他去了爱尔兰的戈尔韦。他还一路去了冰岛。完全正确，汤姆。所以他绝对
went to West Africa. The Portuguese are very busy in West Africa. The Portuguese have a business model that the Spanish do not follow. So this is why it actually really matters that Columbus ends up sailing for Spain rather than for Portugal. So this is why it actually really matters that Columbus ends up sailing for Spain rather than for Portugal. So the Portuguese business model is they will establish trading posts, fortresses, but they don't tend to settle. So the Portuguese have this very famous sort of slaving fortress called Elmina on the Gold Coast, Guinea. And they are basically buying slaves there and shipping them to Madeira. Columbus almost certainly visited that. And he would have traveled on these Portuguese,
去过西非。葡萄牙人在西非非常活跃。葡萄牙人有一种西班牙人没有遵循的商业模式。所以这就是为什么哥伦布最终为西班牙而不是为葡萄牙航行，其实是如此重要的一点。所以这就是为什么哥伦布最终为西班牙而不是为葡萄牙航行，其实是如此重要的一点。葡萄牙人的商业模式是建立贸易站、要塞，但他们往往不进行定居。所以葡萄牙人在几内亚黄金海岸有一个非常著名的奴隶要塞，叫埃尔米纳。他们基本上在那里购买奴隶并把他们运到马德拉。哥伦布几乎可以肯定是访问过那里的。而且他很可能会乘坐葡萄牙人的这些船只旅行，
these very innovative Portuguese ships called caravels. We know all about them, don't we? Of course, famously, Tom, have triangular sails, triangular rigging. Perhaps you'd like to explain to the listeners what the advantage of a triangular sail is. You're so predictable that you think you can, you would, I thought to myself, Tom will ask me some smug question, snide question about triangular sails to try and expose my ignorance.
这些非常创新的葡萄牙船只被称为卡拉维尔帆船。我们对它们都很了解，对吧？当然，众所周知，汤姆，它们有三角帆，三角索具。也许你想向听众解释一下三角帆的优势是什么？你太好预测了，以至于你觉得你可以，你本会，我当时想：汤姆会问我一些自鸣得意的问题，关于三角帆的挖苦问题，试图暴露我的无知。
Have you mastered it? Well, it's all a question of Latin rigging, Tom, as I'm sure you know. So they've picked up the practice of Latin rigging from the Arabs. Latin rigging means you do have triangular rigging around the square. It means you're quicker.
你掌握了吗？这全关乎拉丁帆装，汤姆，我相信你很清楚。所以他们从阿拉伯人那里学到了拉丁帆装的做法。拉丁帆装意味着你在正方形周围确实有三角帆装。这意味着你速度更快。
It means you're more maneuverable. So yeah, so you didn't think i would be prepared for this no i feel like the ramens blundering into yeah an ambush set by hannibal a german forest that's what it is yes that's the battle of the teutoburg forest that's what this episode will be remembered for i'm glad you thought and the winds are very important and we'll come to them they're terribly important but just you mentioned about going north. He does go north. He goes to Iceland and he goes to Ireland and probably to Bristol. And at this point in the 15th century, there's a lot of sort of gossip about whether there
这意味着你机动性更强。所以，是的，你没想到我会对此有所准备吧？不，我感觉自己像个罗马人，鲁莽地闯入了……是的，一个由汉尼拔设下的埋伏，一片日耳曼森林。就是这样，对吧？是的，那是条顿堡森林战役，这场播客将因此而被记住。我很高兴你想到了这一点。风向非常重要，我们待会儿会谈到，它们极其重要。不过刚才你提到去北方。他确实去了北方。他去了冰岛、爱尔兰，可能还有布里斯托尔。在15世纪的这个时候，有很多关于西方是否可能存在某种东西的闲话。所以人们谈论一个虚构的岛屿，他们称之为安蒂利亚（Antia）。因此，我们得到的“安的列斯群岛”（Antilles）这个词就是这么来的。非常重要的一点是，据说该岛是由逃离西班牙阿拉伯入侵的葡萄牙难民建立的。
could be something to the west. So people talk about an imaginary island, which they call Antia. Hence, that's where we get the word Antilles from. And that, very importantly, is supposedly to have been settled by Portuguese refugees from the Arab invasions of Spain. Yeah, exactly. So this idea that there is a Portuguese settlement somewhere out there. I mean, these may be, who knows whether some of these things may be kind of folk memories of the Viking expeditions. Contact with Greenland was probably lost only a generation or two before Columbus was born.
是的，完全正确。所以这种观点认为，那里某处有一个葡萄牙定居点。我的意思是，谁知道其中某些事情是否可能是维京远征的民间记忆呢？与格陵兰岛的联系可能在哥伦布出生前一两代人时就断了。
So it's possible. But the other island that people think is out there is an island called Brazil. Yes. So people have a sort of fantasy of Brazil before Brazil itself exists. The derivation is different, I think. So Brazil today, as in Pele and everything, derives from the name of a tree that apparently gives a red dye. Some people think the tree is named after the legendary island so actually it became self-fulfilling but the brazil that people
所以这是可能的。但人们认为存在的另一个岛屿是一个叫“巴西”（Brazil）的岛屿。是的。所以人们在巴西本身存在之前，就对巴西有了一种幻想。我认为词源是不同的。所以今天的巴西，就像贝利和所有这些一样，源于一种据称能提供红色染料的树的名字。有些人认为这棵树是以这个传奇岛屿命名的，所以实际上它成了自我实现的预言。但是人们在
in the um before the discovery of the new world are talking about is set in the north atlantic it is indeed and it reflects these contradictions that people in bristol perhaps you know there's the idea that sailors from bristol perhaps are going to Newfoundland or even before Columbus discovers America to go fishing there. Might Columbus have picked up reports of Greenland and maybe even Vinland in Iceland? I mean, if he's gone as far as Iceland, why wouldn't he have picked up rumors of something out there to the west? And then there's this extraordinary detail that he reports having seen flat faced castaways in Galway that he thinks might have come from Cathay. And he cites as well a note of Indian merchants who supposedly had come ashore in Germany in the 12th century. So he's obviously starting to kind of pick up these maybe folk tales
新大陆发现之前所谈论的那个“巴西”，是位于北大西洋的。确实如此，它反映了这些矛盾：布里斯托尔的人们——或许，你知道，有一种观点认为来自布里斯托尔的水手甚至在哥伦布发现美洲之前就已经前往纽芬兰甚至去那里捕鱼了。哥伦布是否可能在冰岛收集到了关于格陵兰岛甚至文兰的报告呢？我的意思是，如果他已经走到了冰岛那么远，他怎么可能没有收集到关于西方某个地方的传言呢？然后还有一个非凡的细节，他报告说在戈尔韦看到了扁平脸的船难幸存者，他认为他们可能来自契丹（Cathay）。他还列举了一则据称在12世纪登陆德国的印度商人的记录。所以他显然开始收集这些民间传说，
of people coming across the Atlantic from, as he sees it, Asia. Because that's the key, isn't it? What does he think might be out there? Well, that's the key, isn't it? What does he think might be out there? Well, that's the thing. I think there's a lot of speculation at the time. And I think we don't have much of a sense of Columbus the man at this point. You know, he's, what is he, late teens, early twenties. We know he's a Genoese mariner. That's all we know. But we do start to get a sense of him. He's the sort of 15th century equivalent of somebody who spent an enormous amount of time in his bedroom reading strange forums on the internet, don't you think? Yes.
关于人们从他眼中的亚洲横渡大西洋的传说。因为这才是关键，不是吗？他认为那里面可能有什么？好吧，这才是关键，不是吗？他认为那里面可能有什么？好吧，就是这样。我认为当时有很多猜测。而且我认为此时我们对哥伦布这个人的感觉不多。你知道，他是，他是什么时候？十几岁末、二十岁初。我们知道他是一名热那亚水手。这就是我们所知道的全部。但我们确实开始对他有了点感觉。他有点像15世纪版本的、花了大量时间在卧室里阅读互联网上奇怪论坛的人，你不觉得吗？是的。
You know, he's picking up everything he can from kind of in presumably sailors' taverns and on ships. And he's fascinated by this idea of Asia, which we'll come to in a second. We wouldn't have Christopher Columbus, we wouldn't be doing this podcast, I think, had he not been involved with Portugal, because it's his involvement with the kind of Portuguese merchant marine that means that he's exposed to all this stuff. We always think of this as a Spanish story, or indeed a peculiarly individual story for two reasons. One, because obviously he ends up doing it in the name of Spain. And secondly, because it's very important to Columbus as part of his insecurity, that he's this kind of lonely man of destiny, operating in the face of a world that doesn't understand him and doesn't agree with him and doubts his theories. That really is sort of tosh. One of the great historians who writes about this,
你知道，他从水手酒馆和船上尽可能地吸收他能吸收的一切。他对亚洲的概念着迷，我们一会儿就会谈到。如果没有与葡萄牙的交集，我们就不会有克里斯托弗·哥伦布，我们也不会做这个播客，我认为，正是因为他参与了葡萄牙商船队，他才接触到了所有这些东西。我们总是认为这是一个西班牙的故事，或者确实是一个极其个人的故事，原因有二。第一，显然因为他最终是以西班牙的名义完成这件事的。第二，因为这对于哥伦布的不安全感非常重要，他认为自己是一个孤独的命运之子，在一个不理解他、不同意他的观点、怀疑他的理论的世界里面对这一切。这实际上纯属胡扯。其中一位撰写相关内容的伟大历史学家，
a chap called Matthew Restle, who I think is at Ohio State University, he actually really downplays Columbus. He says, Columbus's discoveries were an accidental geographical byproduct of Portuguese expansion two centuries old, of Portuguese-Castilian competition for Atlantic control a century old, and of Portuguese-Castilian competition for a sea route to India older than Columbus himself. So in other words, Columbus is the product of a milieu in which people are competing to get into the Atlanticlantic and they are swapping all kinds of ideas and theories so we mentioned antia and brazil there's also an idea about the antipodes so i think the greeks had speculated about whether there might be something called the antipodes strabo because the idea that the globe everything must be balanced so there must
一个叫马修·雷斯尔的家伙，我想他在俄亥俄州立大学，他其实大大贬低了哥伦布。他说：“哥伦布的发现是葡萄牙两个世纪扩张的偶然地理副产品，是葡萄牙与卡斯蒂利亚争夺大西洋控制权一个世纪以来的竞争产物，也是葡萄牙与卡斯蒂利亚争夺通往印度海路这一比哥伦布本人还要古老的竞争的产物。”换句话说，哥伦布是一群人的产物，在这个环境中，人们在争相进入大西洋，他们交流着各种各样的想法和理论。所以我们提到了安蒂利亚和巴西，还有一个关于对跖点的想法。我想希腊人曾推测是否存在一种叫做对跖点的东西，斯特拉波认为，因为地球上的一切都必须保持平衡，所以必须
be a continent to balance the continent of eurasia and africa on the other side of the globe, everything must be balanced. So there must be a continent to balance the continent of Eurasia and Africa on the other side of the globe. Which would be Australia, I suppose. One thing that probably some listeners will be saying was, well, didn't everybody think that the world was flat? And that is probably the single biggest misconception about the 15th century that exists because no educated person, no even remotely educated person in the 15th century thinks the world is flat. I think for about 700, 800 years, it has been recognized, including by the Catholic Church, that the world is round. And actually, the idea that Columbus thought the world was round and everybody else thought it was flat is a 19th century invention
有一个大陆来平衡欧亚大陆和非洲大陆。在地球的另一端，一切都必须保持平衡。所以必须有一个大陆来平衡欧亚大陆和非洲大陆在地球另一端的存在。那大概就是澳大利亚吧。有些听众可能会问的一个问题是：“难道不是所有人都认为世界是平的吗？”这可能是关于15世纪存在的最大误解，因为在15世纪，没有一个受过教育的人——哪怕是略受教育的人——会认为世界是平的。我想大约七八百年以来，包括天主教会内，人们就已经承认世界是圆的。事实上，认为哥伦布以为世界是圆的而其他所有人都以为世界是平的，是19世纪美国作家华盛顿·欧文发明出来的。
by the American writer, Washington Irving. Everything is invented in the 19th century, isn't it? Well, Washington Irving, isn't he the Night Before Christmas? Is he the Night Before Christmas? Yes, he is. Yes. And he writes about the Alhambra. Yes, he did write about the Alhambra. Yes. So no, people think the world is round and they think there might be something out there. And the idea is sort of changing hands more quickly than ever, because of course, printing has been invented. So in 1450, Gutenberg has invented the printing press. You got the first printed books in the Iberian Peninsula by about the 1470s. So Columbus is living in a world of books where he can read up on ideas and rumours and all of these things. So in the 14 1480s he actually becomes a book dealer right yes
每样东西都是在19世纪发明的，不是吗？好吧，华盛顿·欧文，他不是《圣诞节前夜》的作者吗？他是《圣诞节前夜》的作者吗？是的，他是。是的。他写过《阿尔罕布拉宫》。是的，他确实写过《阿尔罕布拉宫》。是的。所以，不，人们认为世界是圆的，并且认为那里可能有什么东西。而且这些想法比以往任何时候都流传得更快，因为印刷术已经被发明了。所以在1450年，古腾堡发明了印刷术。你在1470年代左右在伊比利亚半岛就有了第一批印刷书籍。所以哥伦布生活在一个书籍的世界里，在那里他可以阅读各种想法、谣言和所有这些东西。所以在1480年代，他实际上成了一个书商。
he kind of stops doing his navigating and things and that's in lisbon in lisbon yeah and it's a sign of how settled he is but he's also he's married by this point he's married a portuguese woman philip philippa is that yeah yeah philippa yeah so in 1478 and she is technically a noblewoman because her father, I gather, had been awarded this kind of barren remote island out in the Atlantic. And this seems also kind of very, very important insight into Columbus's character, but also the mood of the time, because there is something chivalric about these explorations going out into the sea. And Columbus as a bookseller presumably would have been very fired by that because there are all these romances being written and being published in which kind of the equivalents of Knights Errant are going out into the sea and having spectacular adventures and winning island kingdoms.
对的，是的。他有点停止了航海之类的活动，那是在里斯本。在里斯本，是的。这标志着他安定了下来，而且他到这个时候已经结婚了。他娶了一个葡萄牙女人，菲莉帕，是吗？对，对，菲莉帕，是的。所以是在1478年。她严格来说是一位贵族女性，因为据我了解，她的父亲曾被授予大西洋上一个荒凉偏远的岛屿。这似乎也是对哥伦布性格的一个非常、非常重要的洞察，同时也反映了那个时代的风貌，因为这些向海里进发的探险有一种骑士精神。而哥伦布作为一名书商，大概会深受其鼓舞，因为当时有那么多骑士文学被撰写和出版，其中骑士们的化身们出海进行壮观的冒险并赢得岛屿王国。
And again, you can see that this is part of the swirl of the cultural context that must be influencing columbus this idea you know his own father-in-law has made himself the lord of a barren island so why shouldn't columbus definitely tom i couldn't agree with you more so the most famous of all those chivalric romances which is tyron leblanc um which is in valencian and that appeared i think 1490 so two years before Columbus sales. And he's absolutely part of that milieu. So there are stories about people. Knights venture out and they fight giants and they meet people with no heads,
同样，你可以看到这是影响哥伦布的文化背景漩涡的一部分，这种想法——你知道，他自己的岳父让自己成为了一座荒凉岛屿的领主，所以哥伦布为什么不能呢？绝对的，汤姆，我不能同意你更多了。所以所有这些骑士传奇中最著名的是《蒂朗·白朗》（Tirant lo Blanc），是用巴伦西亚语写的，我想它出现在1490年，也就是哥伦布出海前两年。他绝对是那种环境的一部分。所以有很多关于人们的故事。骑士们出海去与巨人战斗，他们遇到没有头、
with their heads in their chests or whatever. And Amazons, they're obsessed with Amazons. Yeah, Columbus is obsessed by Amazons, isn't he? Well, he's told at various points. People are always being told. And Cortez, when he went to Mexico, was specifically told, find out where the Amazons are. I mean, people don't think the Amazons are made up.
头长在胸口之类的人，还有亚马逊人。他们对亚马逊人着迷。是的，哥伦布对亚马逊人着迷，不是吗？嗯，他在不同阶段都被告知过。人们总是被告知。而科尔特斯去墨西哥时，也被明确告知：去找出亚马逊人在哪里。我的意思是，人们并不认为亚马逊人是虚构的。
They really think they're out there. And we can sort of laugh about this because we know better, as it were. But there's a tremendous sense of excitement. And I mean, enlightenment is the wrong word, but there's a sort of questing sense to it, isn't there? You know, there's something out there. It's an intellectual as much as a physical challenge to work out what is there. So Columbus, he is a deeply religious man. I mean, he is intensely pious. And if you miss that side of him, you really miss what makes him tick. So he's very serious. I'm not going to miss that, Dominic.
他们真的认为那些人在外面。我们可以对此一笑了之，因为正如我们所知，我们见多识广。但有一种巨大的兴奋感。我的意思是，“启蒙”这个词用得不对，但其中有一种探索的意味，不是吗？你知道，外面有什么东西。搞清楚那里有什么，既是一场物理挑战，也是一场智力挑战。所以哥伦布，他是一个极其虔诚的人。我的意思是，他极其虔诚。如果你忽视了他这一面，你真的就抓不住他的精髓了。所以他是非常严肃的。我不会忽视这一点的，多米尼克。
No, well, you're not going to miss it it i'm worried about the listeners tom i'm not worried about you could i could i just mention about his name yeah i i think i'm not the only one i've of course others think this as well and i'm merely following in their footsteps no no this is based on your own close research right but it did strike me even before i i had this this assumption confirmed by reading up on it, that his name must have had an influence on how he saw his destiny. Because Christopher, it's Christopher carrying Christ, the giant who carries Christ on his shoulders.
不，好吧，你不会忽视的。我担心的是听众，汤姆，我不是在担心你。我……我能提一下他的名字吗？是的。我想我不是唯一一个——当然其他人也这么想，我只是在效仿他们的做法。不，不，这完全是基于你自己的深入研究，对吧？但它确实让我甚至在我通过阅读证实这种假设之前就有一个印象，即他的名字一定对他是如何看待自己的命运产生了影响。因为克里斯托弗（Christopher），就是背负基督的人（Christ-bearer），那个把基督扛在肩上的巨人。
The idea that across water, the idea that you are taking Christ across water. So that's implicit in one name. And Columbus, Latin for dove, and the dove is the symbol of the Holy Spirit. The Holy Spirit is incredibly important to Columbus because he comes to identify with the Franciscans, the order of friars who are founded by obviously St. Francis. And they are very, very enthused by the idea that there have been three ages, the age of the father, the age of the son, and now that the age of the father the age of the son and now that the age of the spirit is dawning and i think columbus sees himself as as the embodiment of that idea the idea that perhaps a new age is dawning and that he is destined by his name to play a role in it i mean do you think
这种跨越水域的概念，把基督带过水域的概念。所以这是隐含在一个名字里的。而哥伦布（Columbus），拉丁语中是“鸽子”的意思，而鸽子是圣灵的象征。圣灵对哥伦布来说极其重要，因为他开始认同方济各会，这个由圣方济各创立的修士会。他们非常、非常热衷于这样一种观点：历史上曾有过三个时代：父的时代、子的时代，而现在，
i think that's that kind of mystical sense of his destiny oh he's definitely got a mystical sense so later on actually you know what what bears out your theory is that later on he he starts signing after he's gone a bit mad he's gone a little bit mad later on he does sign his letters the christ bearer or the christ carrier that sort of so that thing about his his name christopher also the holy spirit isn't that holy spirit that moves upon the waters yes something like that so yes it does yes like like columbus so anyway he's reading his bible he's reading religious stuff he's also reading his he's reading lots of different things so he probably reads marco polo marco polo of course claims that he has been to cafe to china and
父的时代、子的时代，而现在，圣灵的时代正在破晓。我认为哥伦布把自己视为那种思想的化身：一个新时代可能正在破晓，而他命中注定要通过自己的名字在其中扮演一个角色。我的意思是，你觉得……我认为那种神秘的命运感……哦，他绝对有一种神秘的命运感。所以后来，实际上，你知道什么印证了你的理论吗？那就是后来他在——当他有点疯了之后——他后来在信件上签名时自称为“基督的担负者”（Christ bearer）或者“基督的运载者”（Christ carrier），诸如此类。所以关于他的名字克里斯托弗，还有圣灵，难道不是圣灵运行在水面上吗？是的，类似的东西。所以是的，确实如此。就像哥伦布一样。无论如何，他在读圣经，他在读宗教的东西。他还在读他的……他读了很多不同的东西。所以他可能读了马可·波罗。马可·波罗当然声称他去过契丹，也就是中国，而且
marco polo says i guess has all sorts of stories about people with the heads of dogs and amazons again he says what he calls chipupangu, Japan, is about 1,500 miles. Because Marco Polo is the first European who is aware of the existence of Japan. Exactly. And he says Chupangu is about 1,500 miles east of China. And so people at that point start thinking, well, if it really is as far away from China as that, we could use it as a way station. We could sail west, we'd get to Chupangu, and then we'd go on to Cathay. So he's reading that. He reads a really, really important book by a guy who had previously been the confessor to the King of France,
马可·波罗说，我想，他有关于长着狗头的怪物和亚马逊人的各种故事。再次，他说他所称的“齐潘古”（Chipupangu），也就是日本，大约在1500英里之外。因为马可·波罗是第一个意识到日本存在的欧洲人。完全正确。他说齐潘古位于中国以东约1500英里处。所以当时的人们开始想，好吧，如果它离中国真的有那么远，我们可以把它当作一个中转站。我们可以向西航行，到达齐潘古，然后继续前往契丹。所以他在读这些。他读了一本非常、非常重要的书，作者是一个曾担任法王忏悔师的家伙，
who was a guy called Pierre Dailly, called Imago Mundi. And this French bloke says, I think you can cross the Atlantic. I think it is possible. I've worked out a way to do it. Is he the guy who argues that the world is smaller than people thought and therefore it's possible? Well, he's one of a whole number of people who are making that kind of argument. The one who is most famous, the most influential on Columbus
那个人叫皮埃尔·代伊（Pierre d'Ailly），书名叫《世界宝鉴》（Imago Mundi）。这个法国佬说：“我认为你可以横渡大西洋。我认为这是可能的。我已经研究出了一种方法。”他是那个认为世界比人们想象的要小、因此这是可能的争论者吗？好吧，他是众多提出这种论点的人之一。最著名的一个、对哥伦布影响最大的是一个来自佛罗伦萨的家伙，名叫托斯卡内利（Toscanelli）。托斯卡内利给了他——或者说哥伦布弄到了一批托斯卡内利的信件。托斯卡内利计算过你可以向西航行去中国，正是因为这个原因。他说大西洋绝不像人们想象的那么宽阔。实际上，那些说……
is a guy from Florence who is called Toscanelli. And Toscanelli gives him or Columbus gets a load called Toscanelli. And Toscanelli gives him, or Columbus gets, a load of Toscanelli's letters. Toscanelli has worked out that you can sail west to China because exactly that. He says the Atlantic is not anything like as broad as has been thought. That actually, these people saying,
是一个来自佛罗伦萨的叫托斯卡内利的人。托斯卡内利给他，或者说哥伦布得到了托斯卡内利的一堆信件。托斯卡内利计算出你可以向西航行到中国，因为事实确实如此。他说大西洋远不像人们想象的那么宽阔。实际上，这些人说，
Marco Polo had massively overestimated how far away China was from Europe. So he'd put hundreds and hundreds of miles onto the distance. Now, if that is the case, if Eurasia is much bigger, then almost by definition, because people have a vague sense of how big the world is, that means the Atlantic must be smaller. So maybe it would just be if you know it's fewer days sail than you would expect to go to japan and columbus it to use that and i'll go back to that analogy of the sort of the teenager in his bedroom reading on the dark web you know reading wacky theories about covid or russia or whatever columbus is reading all this stuff about the Atlantic and he becomes completely convinced that as it were, the mainstream media are misrepresenting the size of the Atlantic
马可·波罗大大高估了中国距离欧洲有多远。因此，他在实际距离上凭空添加了数百甚至上千英里。如果真是这样，如果欧亚大陆大得多，那么几乎可以肯定——由于人们对世界的大小有一个模糊的概念——这意味着大西洋必定更小。所以，或许去日本航行的天数会比你预期的要少，而哥伦布正是利用了这一点。我还是要回到那个类比：就像一个在卧室里深网冲浪的青少年，看著那些关于新冠病毒、俄罗斯或者其他什么的疯狂理论一样，哥伦布阅读了所有关于大西洋的资料，他变得完全坚信，正如人们所说的那样，主流媒体在大西洋的大小上误导了大家，
and that you can cross it. But Dominic, isn't there also the fact that he kind of needs to believe that because if he wants to go on this voyage across the Atlantic, he needs a sponsor. To get a sponsor, he needs to convince the sponsor that it's going to be worth their while. And if it's Antipodes, who knows what might be there? You can't be sure. If it's just a bunch of islands, like the Canary Islands or whatever, well, so what? But if you can get to Asia with all its spices, get to India with all its wealth, silk, spices, and so on, then that's great. Absolutely right, Tom.
并且你是可以横渡它的。但是多米尼克，难道还有一个事实是，他某种程度上需要相信这一点吗？因为如果他想进行这趟横渡大西洋的航行，他需要一个赞助人。为了得到赞助人，他必须说服赞助人这绝对物超所值。如果那是极地对蹠地，谁知道那里会有什么？你无法确定。如果只是一堆岛屿，比如加那利群岛什么的，那又怎样呢？但如果你能到达拥有无数香料的亚洲，到达拥有无数财富、丝绸、香料等等的印度，那可就太棒了。完全正确，汤姆。
Absolutely right. So he kind of, I mean, I can see that he believes it. He comes to believe it. But basically, it needs to be Asia because otherwise he's not going to get the sponsorship. Yeah. Is that right? Right. So you probably could, might be able to get sponsorship if you said there's something
完全正确。所以他某种程度上——我的意思是，我能看出他是真的相信了。他开始相信这一点。但基本上，它必须是亚洲，否则他拉不到赞助。对吗？对的。所以你或许可以——如果你说那里有什么
like the Canary Islands where he can grow sugar, as long as it's not too far away. But you're absolutely right. If it's another continent, well, who knows what's there? Who cares? It's a lot of money. But if it's Japan and China and the Indies with all their spices, which people absolutely know are there, and they know that this stuff is very valuable, then of course, it's much more attractive. He absolutely needs state sponsorship. He's like a man dreaming of a tech startup or something who needs state sponsorship, not just because he needs the sort of, as it were,
类似于加那利群岛那样可以种植甘蔗的地方，只要距离不是太远，你可能还能拉到赞助。但你说的完全没错。如果那是另一个大陆，谁知道那里有什么？谁在乎呢？那得花一大笔钱。但如果那是日本、中国和印度群岛，以及它们那些人们绝对知道存在且价值连城的香料，那么，当然，这就吸引人多了。他绝对需要国家赞助。他就像一个梦想著搞科技创业之类的人，需要国家的赞助，不仅因为他需要那种——可以说是——
the venture capital, but there's no point getting to somewhere and then not being backed up by a state because somebody will take it from you straight away. You need a state to defend it, to say, this is our concession. This is our trading port, whatever it might be. And so the question then becomes, which state?
风险投资，而且你千辛万苦到达某个地方却得不到国家的支撑是毫无意义的，因为别人会立刻把它从你手中夺走。你需要一个国家来保卫它，宣称这是我们的租借地，这是我们的贸易港，无论它是什么。于是问题就变成了：哪个国家？
And I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, let's look at how it is that Columbus comes to get the sponsors that he ends up with. We'll be back in a few minutes. I'm Marina Hyde. And i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of entertainmentisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我想我们这时候该休息一下了。等我们回来，让我们看看哥伦布是如何最终找到那些赞助人的。几分钟后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐至上》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝娱乐圈八卦的固定栏目，在我们的问答环节中，我们为娱乐行业揭开神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票的福利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are telling the story of Christopher Columbus. And Dominic, when we left, he is in Lisbon. He is married. He's had a son who will be called by the Spanish Diego. He is a book dealer. He has a background in sailing, both in the Mediterranean and the Atlantic. And he's starting to get this idea that perhaps it's possible to cross the Atlantic and get to Asia. But he needs a state sponsor. So he's in Portugal.
大家好，欢迎回到《历史的沉淀》（The Rest Is History）。我们正在讲述克里斯托弗·哥伦布的故事。多米尼克，在我们刚才讲到的时候，他在里斯本。他结婚了。他有了一个儿子，后来西班牙人叫他迭戈。他是一名书商。他有在地中海和大西洋航行的背景。他开始产生这样一个想法：也许有可能横渡大西洋并到达亚洲。但他需要一个国家赞助人。所以他在葡萄牙。
So presumably he turns to the king of Portugal, does he? He does indeed. Before I say that, I will just say one thing, which is that turns to the king of Portugal, does he? He does indeed. Before I say that, I will just say one thing, which is that I'm very relieved, Tom, that you didn't bring us back in with your soprano's voice, which I thought was possible. And we've dodged a bit of a bullet there, I think we can all say. Yeah, Portugal's the obvious place to go.
所以他大概是去找葡萄牙国王了，对吧？他的确去了。在我说这个之前，我只想说一件事，那就是我很欣慰，汤姆，你没有用你那男高音的嗓音把我们带回来，我之前觉得这完全有可能。我想我们可以一致认为，我们算是逃过了一劫。是的，葡萄牙是显而易去的地方。
The Portuguese are the big expansionists. He's in Portugal. He has Portuguese connections. So he goes to King Zhao II friend of the show very much a friend of the rest is history we did a whole series
葡萄牙人是大规模扩张的急先锋。他在葡萄牙。他有人脉。所以他去找了若昂二世国王，——本节目的好朋友，绝对是《历史的沉淀》的好朋友，我们去年做过一整套
about Portugal and the age of discovery last year so if you haven't heard that do check it out now the Portuguese I mean the funny thing is
关于葡萄牙与大航海时代的系列节目，所以如果你还没听过，现在就去看看吧。关于葡萄牙人，有趣的是，
they turn him down so it's a bit like sort of Decker turning down the Beatles or something but the thing is the Portuguese are absolutely right
他们拒绝了他，所以这有点像Decca唱片公司拒绝甲壳虫乐队之类的。但问题是，葡萄牙人完全是正确的。
so right away they identify the flaw in the plan. They say, we don't believe. So the king commissions a commission of inquiry to look into this. And they say, you know, Japan is much further away than you think it is. Your calculations are all wrong. You will not get to Asia. No expedition can be kitted out with enough food and water. No crew will stay
所以他们立刻指出了这个计划中的致命缺陷。他们说：“我们不信。”因此，国王委任了一个调查委员会来研究此事。他们说：“你知道，日本比你想像的要远得多。你的计算全错了。你根本到不了亚洲。任何探险队都不可能配备足够的水和食物。没有任何船员会愿意
kind of quiescent for so long. And in all that, the Portuguese are completely and utterly right. And Columbus, ironically, is completely and utterly wrong. But also the Portuguese have understood that the best way to get to India, which is really where people want to get to, is going down the coast of Africa around the Cape of Good Hope. And that's the focus of all their energies and efforts, right? The Portuguese are too successful for Columbus because their eastward voyages, their voyages around Africa are incredibly lucrative. They're going great guns down there, sort of Bartholomew Diaz, Diego Cao, all these people going around the Cape of Good Hope.
保持这种平静的状态这么久。”在所有这些方面，葡萄牙人完全而且彻底地是对的。而讽刺的是，哥伦布完全而且彻底地错了。但与此同时，葡萄牙人已经明白，去印度的最佳方式——这也是人们真正想去的地方——是沿着非洲海岸线绕过好望角。那是他们所有精力和努力的焦点，对吧？对于哥伦布来说，葡萄牙人实在是太成功了，因为他们向东的航行、他们绕过非洲的航行利润极其丰厚。他们在那里干得热火朝天，像巴托洛梅乌·迪亚士、迪奥戈·康这些人都在绕过好望角。
This is all an absolute triumph for them. Why are they going to throw away a load of money on an expedition that, as their own experts say, is completely sort of, is crackers? They see Columbus as a crank. I suppose he is a crank. Well, he is. Yes. I mean, this is the irony that he's both. A visionary and a crank.
这对他们来说绝对是一场巨大的胜利。他们凭什么要在一场按他们自己的专家所说完全是荒唐透顶的探险上挥霍大量资金呢？他们把哥伦布视为一个怪胎。我想他确实是个怪胎。嗯，他的确是。是的。我的意思是，这就是讽刺之处，他既是一个有远见的人，又是一个怪胎。
Yes, that's what I was going to say. He's a visionary and a crank. Exactly right. Exactly. Exactly. Kind of Elon Musk- crank. Exactly right. Exactly, exactly. Kind of Elon Musk-esque, only not as rich, obviously. Yeah, so much less rich and more Italian, Elon Musk, I think, if you can imagine that. So where does he turn next?
是的，这正是我要说的。他既是一个有远见的人，又是一个怪胎。完全正确。绝对没错。绝对的。有点像埃隆·马斯克式的怪胎。完全正确。绝对的，绝对的。有点像埃隆·马斯克，只不过当然没那么有钱。对，没那么有钱，而且更像个意大利人，埃隆·马斯克，如果你能想像得到的话。那么他接下来转向了哪里？
He turns to Castile. So Castile is Portugal's kind of rival on the Iberian Peninsula, really. Castile has been united with Aragon, another Spanish kingdom, through marriage, the union of the crowns of Ferdinand of Aragon and Isabella of Castile in 1479. The Castilians have already expanded a little bit, not as much as the Portuguese. They've taken the Canary Islands, and they are fighting a war to conquer Granada. Now, I mentioned the Canary Islands. That is, again, this idea that Columbus comes out of this kind of clear blue sky is not right, because the Canary Islands are kind
他转向了卡斯蒂利亚。所以卡斯蒂利亚可以说是伊比利亚半岛上葡萄牙的竞争对手。卡斯蒂利亚通过阿拉贡的斐迪南和卡斯蒂利亚的伊莎贝拉在1479年的王室联姻，与另一个西班牙王国阿拉贡合并了。卡斯蒂利亚人已经进行了一点扩张，虽然没有葡萄牙人那么多。他们占领了加那利群岛，并且正在打一场征服格拉纳达的战争。现在，我提到了加那利群岛。再次说明，认为哥伦布的设想是从晴朗的天空中凭空冒出来的这种想法是不对的，因为加那利群岛有点
of like an experiment. They're like a laboratory in which the Spanish colonization of the Americas is already, in a weird way, underway. So they're using private finance. There are arguments on the Canary Islands, should we convert the indigenous people to Christianity or should we enslave them? And they've imported an alien crop, sugar, and started plantations right there in the Canary Islands. So there in embryo, you can actually see so many of the patterns that will change life in what's now Latin America forever. But also, you can see patterns that will change, that will be introduced
像一个实验。它们就像一个实验室，西班牙对美洲的殖民在其中以一种奇特的方式已经拉开了帷幕。所以他们使用的是私人资金。加那利群岛上存在著争论：我们应该把原住民归依基督教，还是应该把他们奴役？他们还在加那利群岛引进了外来的农作物——甘蔗，并在那里开辟了种植园。所以在萌芽状态中，你实际上可以看到许多日后永远改变拉丁美洲生活的模式。不仅如此，你还能看到这些模式将在伊比利亚半岛本土就被引入并改变美洲。因为你提到了针对格拉纳达的战争。这是持续了数个世纪的漫长过程的一部分，即收复失地运动（Reconquista），也就是试图收复很久以前被阿拉伯人征服的大片西班牙领土。这是一个非常、非常成功但历时漫长的过程。现在只剩下一个王国了，那就是格拉纳达王国。实际上，留着格拉纳达对西班牙君主斐迪南和伊莎贝拉来说在财政上更有利，因为格拉纳达国王能够获得从穆斯林南方运上来的所有黄金。因此他可以把这作为贡赋支付。但斐迪南和伊莎贝拉想要吞并格拉纳达，部分原因是
to America within Iberia itself. Because you mentioned the war against Granada. This is part of an ongoing process that's been lasting for centuries, the Reconquista, the attempt to reconquer vast swathes of Spain that have been conquered by the Arabs way back. And it's been a very, very successful, if protracted process. And now there is this one kingdom left, the kingdom of Granada, which actually has been very, very, you know, keeping Granada in one way makes kind of better financial sense for the Spanish monarchs, Ferdinand and Isabella, because the king of Granada has access to all the gold that is coming up from the Muslim south. And so he can pay this as tribute. But Ferdinand and Isabella want to annex Granada partly because
到伊比利亚本土的美洲。因为你提到了对格拉纳达的战争。这是一场已经持续了几个世纪的长期进程的一部分，即收复失地运动，试图收复很久以前被阿拉伯人征服的大片西班牙土地。这是一个非常非常成功但历时持久的过程。现在只剩下一个王国了，即格拉纳达王国，实际上，从某种角度来看，保留格拉纳达对西班牙君主斐迪南和伊莎贝拉来说在财政上更有利，因为格拉纳达国王可以接触到从穆斯林南部运上来的所有黄金。因此他可以将其作为贡品支付。但是斐迪南和伊莎贝拉想要兼并格拉纳达，部分原因是
they feel that it's a Trojan horse. It's a danger with the great Muslim power of the Ottomans spreading westwards. But also I think because they feel a sense of destiny. They feel that they've been called upon by God to redeem the whole of Iberia for Christendom. And it's that mixture of hard-headed commercial sense and apocalyptic feeling of self-appointment that will infuse the spirit of the Spanish conquistadors in the new world. Yeah, that's absolutely right. They have a profound sense of mission, don't they? They see themselves as appointed by God. They're very in with the Pope. They want to wipe Granada off the map. And that sort of crusading zeal, I mean, crusading is absolutely the word because
他们觉得这是一匹特洛伊木马。随着强大的奥斯曼穆斯林势力向西扩张，这是一个危险。但我也认为是因为他们有一种使命感。他们觉得上帝召唤他们为基督教赎回整个伊比利亚。正是这种务实的商业意识与末日般的天命感的结合，将注入新世界西班牙征服者的精神中。是的，完全正确。他们有一种深刻的使命感，不是吗？他们认为自己是上帝指定的。他们与教皇关系很好。他们想把格拉纳达从地图上抹去。那种十字军东征的热情，我的意思是，十字军东征绝对是这个词，因为
Ferdinand of Aragon, his great obsession is to go on crusade, is to recapture Jerusalem. And actually, one of the reasons he ends up investing in columbus's scheme is because he thinks this will give me money for what i really want to do which is to launch a crusade so that because the spanish have this idea that the last emperor of all who will capture jerusalem and then the second coming will begin yeah is is lurking somewhere el encubierto the the the hidden one and ferdinand dare i think starts to you know just to nurture the possibility that perhaps that's who he is so so that kind of columbus has a kind of crankish element ferdinand is not entirely hostile to that no i think you're right tom and then some friars actually have told ferdinand you probably are that last emperor which is it must be a nice thing to to hear i mean it's quite
阿拉贡的斐迪南，他最大的痴迷就是进行十字军东征，夺回耶路撒冷。事实上，他最终决定投资哥伦布计划的原因之一，是他认为这会为他真正想做的事情提供资金，也就是发动一场十字军东征。因为西班牙人有这样一种想法：收复耶路撒冷并开启第二次降临的终极之王——是的，正潜伏在某个地方，即“隐匿者”（el encubierto）——而斐迪南，我敢说，开始（哪怕只是）去酝酿这样一种可能性：也许他自己就是那个人。所以，哥伦布身上有一种怪胎般的元素，而斐迪南对此也并非完全排斥。不，我想你是对的，汤姆。后来一些修道士甚至告诉斐迪南，你很可能就是那个最后的帝王，听到这话感觉一定很不错。我的意思是，这责任可真够重大的。我想确实是个沉重的责任，但是，如果你有那么一点自信——哥伦布其实没有，而斐迪南显然有——他会想，“嗯，你知道的，如果这事……”所以哥伦布的第一个落脚点是西班牙南部的拉拉维达（La Rábida）修道院。方济各会。方济各会修道院。这修道院里的人整天都在谈论这些事情。但他们也非常博学。其中一个人后来被证明是当时顶尖的天文学家之一。
a responsibility i suppose it is a big responsibility but you know if you've got a bit of self-confidence which columbus actually doesn't um that ferdinand clearly does he thinks well you know if the cat yeah yeah so columbus's first port of call is a monastery called la rabida which is in the south of Spain. Franciscan. The Franciscan monastery. These guys are full of all this kind of talk in this monastery. But they're also, they're very learned. So one of the people who is there is one of the, it turns out, is actually one of the leading astronomers of the period.
他们觉得这是一个特洛伊木马。随著奥斯曼帝国这个伟大的穆斯林强权向西扩张，这是一个巨大的威胁。但我也认为是因为他们有一种命运感。他们觉得上帝召唤他们为基督教赎回整个伊比利亚半岛。正是这种务实的商业感和末世般的受命感，注入了新世界西班牙征服者的精神中。是的，完全正确。他们有一种强烈的使命感，不是吗？他们视自己为上帝的使者。他们与教皇的关系非常融洽。他们想把格拉纳达从地图上抹去。那种十字军东征般的狂热——我的意思是，十字军东征绝对是贴切的词——因为
He's a guy called Antonio de Marchena. And he gives Columbus loads of books. They also have chats. They talk about the Alexandrian astronomer Ptolemy. They talk about Marco Polo, they're full of all this stuff. They've also got an in with Queen Isabella, because the guy who's running the monastery, a man called Pereth, had previously been her confessor. So they say, get yourself to the Ferdinand and Isabella, they'll probably be very keen on this scheme. So off he goes. And what then happens is this sort of endless series of meetings. It's in some ways quite a sort of tiresome story, because it's constant back and forth. But it's also important because it's testimony to Columbus's persistence, his doggedness. Anybody else would give up. You compared it to a tech startup yeah i mean
他叫安东尼奥·德·马尔切纳（Antonio de Marchena）。他送给哥伦布一大堆书。他们还经常聊天。他们讨论亚历山大港的天文学家托勒密，讨论马可·波罗，满脑子都是这些东西。他们与伊莎贝拉女王还有层关系，因为管理修道院的人名叫佩雷斯（Pereth），曾担任过她的忏悔神父。所以他们对他说：“去找斐迪南和伊莎贝拉吧，他们很可能会对这个计划非常感兴趣。”于是他出发了。接下来发生的就是这一连串没完没了的会面。在某种程度上，这是一个相当烦人的故事，因为总是反反复复。但它也很重要，因为这证明了哥伦布的坚持不懈、顽强固执。换作别人早就放弃了。你把它比作一个科技初创公司。是的，我的意思是，
it's kind of like trying to source money for a genius idea but you have to endless meetings endless board meetings with investors and all that kind of stuff and the humiliation of it yeah and columbus is is absolutely happy to put himself through this so the spanish court at the time is peripatetic it moves around and a lot of the time they're in the saddle because they're sort of prosecuting their war against granada so they're in he has to sort of trudge across what is now spain castile he catches up with them finally in the autumn of 1485 so this is just after the battle of bosworth as a to give it a sort of english reference point.
这有点像为某个天才创意寻找资金，但你必须参加与投资者的无数次会议、无数次董事会会议以及所有此类事情，还要承受那种屈辱。是的，而哥伦布非常乐意让自己经历这一切。当时的西班牙宫廷是游牧式的四处迁徙，他们大部分时间都在马背上，因为他们正在进行针对格拉纳达的战争。因此，他必须跋涉穿过现在的西班牙卡斯蒂利亚。他终于在1485年秋天追上了他们，这大约是在博斯沃思菲尔德战役之后，给出一个英国方面的参照点。
He catches up in a place called Alcalá, which is actually where Catherine of Aragon, their daughter. Yeah, another friend of the show. Very much a friend of the show, where she was born. There he catches up with Queen Isabella. Isabella is a very, very formidable, serious, and pious woman. Devout, very devout. And she is, you know, they're interested. Columbus,
他在一个叫阿尔卡拉（Alcalá）的地方追上了他们，这里实际上也是阿拉贡的凯瑟琳（他们的女儿）出生的地——是的，本节目的另一个好朋友。绝对是本节目的好朋友，她就是在那里出生的。在那里，他赶上了伊莎贝拉女王。伊莎贝拉是一位非常、非常令人敬畏、严肃且虔诚的女性。非常虔诚。而且他们——他们很感兴趣。哥伦布，
it seems like he probably shows them maps. Well, so Columbus is unbelievably persuasive, isn't he? Except it doesn't quite pay off at first. No, of course not, because it's a mad idea. But he's got an in. He has got an in, but also he's pushy because he says right at the beginning, he says to them, I've got this brilliant idea to go over to Asia. I think it can be done. I need a little bit of money, take some ships. What I would like is for you to name me Admiral of the Ocean Sea, Viceroy and Governor, and to make that hereditary. So that thing we were talking about in the first half about Columbus's tremendous chip on his shoulder and his obsession with status, he just comes straight out with it.
看起来他可能向他们展示了地图。那么，哥伦布令人难以置信地具有说服力，不是吗？只是起初并没有完全得到回报。不，当然没有，因为这是一个疯狂的想法。但他有人脉。他有人脉，而且他很强势，因为他在一开始就对他们说：“我有一个去亚洲的绝妙主意。我认为这是可行的。我需要一点资金，给我几艘船。我希望你们封我为海洋海军大督办、总督和总督，并且世袭代代相传。”所以，我们在前半部分谈到的哥伦布那种极度自卑的心态和对地位的执着，他直接就开门见山地提出来了。
And they're kind of, well, you know, that's quite a big concession for something that might not. Anyway, they're quite distracted by the war against Granada, obviously. So once again, a bit like the Portuguese king, they say, well, we'll have an inquiry. We'll have a big discussion. And while that's happening, I king, they say, well, we'll have an inquiry. We'll have a big discussion. And while that's happening, I mean, they're quite generous to him.
而他们觉得——嗯，你知道的，对于一件可能不会成功的事情来说，这是一个相当大的让步。不管怎样，他们显然被对格拉纳达的战争分心了。所以，又一次地，就像葡萄牙国王一样，他们说：“好吧，我们会进行调查。我们会好好讨论一下。”而在调查进行的同时——国王，他们说：“好吧，我们会进行调查。我们会好好讨论一下。而在调查进行的同时——”我的意思是，他们对他相当慷慨。
They say, you can stay at court and we will pay you a pension. So we'll pay your living expenses, basically. That's not a bad deal from Columbus's perspective. So they have this inquiry, which meets in 1486, 1487. The chairman is the Queen's confessor, who's a guy called Talavera, the future Archbishop of Granada. They sit around, they look through all the details, and they say, once again, by the Portuguese, China is much further away than you think it is, and Japan is much further away.
他们说：“你可以留在宫廷里，我们会发给你一笔年金。”所以基本上我们会支付你的生活开支。从哥伦布的角度来看，这还算是一笔不错的交易。于是他们进行了调查，会议在1486年、1487年召开。主席是女王的忏悔神父塔拉韦拉（Talavera），后来的格拉纳达大主教。他们坐在一起，仔细查阅了所有细节，然后说——葡萄牙人也这么说过——中国比你想像的要远得多，日本也远得多。
We don't think you can go there. Talavera later says, all agreed that what the admiral argued could not possibly be true. And again, they are completely right. This is the thing that tradition says is they refused it because the world was flat. The world was flat, which is rubbish. Yeah, they don't think that. They understand cartography and geography better than Columbus does, ironically.
我们认为你到不了那里。塔拉韦拉后来表示：“所有人都一致认为，这位大督办所论述的事情绝对不可能是真的。”再次说明，他们完全是正确的。传统观点认为他们拒绝是因为世界是平的。世界是平的，这完全是胡说八道。是的，他们才不这么认为呢。讽刺的是，他们的制图学和地理学知识比哥伦布还要好。
The weird comparison perhaps is with Galileo, where again, everyone laughs at the people who scoffed at Galileo's ideas, but actually Galileo didn't have the proof. All the side of evidence was on the people who doubted him. But Galileo was right though, Tom, wasn't he? Yes, I suppose that is a difference. Fair enough.
奇怪的对比或许可以和伽利略相比，当时每个人都在嘲笑那些对伽利略的想法嗤之以鼻的人，但实际上伽利略并没有证据。所有的证据都站在怀疑他的人那边。但伽利略是对的，对吧，汤姆？是的，我想这确实是一个区别。好吧。
I mean, Columbus, funnily enough, I mean, we're sort of anticipating what we'll be talking about later, butumbus never ever accepts that he's wrong i mean even when he's been kind of does doesn't he i mean he kind of well he never explicitly admits he never explicitly says it yeah so later on he's trying to get we'll come to this we'll refer to this i'm sure in the next episode he's making his his sailors swear that they've actually seen China and they're actually on Cuba. You know, this sort of thing.
我的意思是，说来有趣，哥伦布——我们有点在预告后面要谈的内容了——哥伦布从来不承认自己错了。我的意思是，即使他已经……不是吗？他某种程度上——他从不明确承认，他从不明确地说出来，是的。所以后来他在努力争取——我们会讲到这个，我相信我们会在下一集中提到——他让他的水手发誓说他们真的看到了中国，而实际上他们是在古巴。你知道的，就是这种事。
And he'll chop their tongues out if they don't. Right. He's completely obsessed by this. Anyway, they say no. The Spanish say no. Back he goes. And Dominic, just before he goes back to Lisbon. Yeah.
如果他们不从，他就割掉他们的舌头。没错。他完全被这个执念控制了。不管怎样，他们拒绝了。西班牙人说不。于是他又回去了。多米尼克，就在他回里斯本之前。是的。
One important thing that does happen in his personal life is that he has a fling with a woman from Cordova. Oh, yes. Beatriz Enriquez and um they have a illegitimate son a fernando who will his wife has died tom to do him justice yeah yeah but but he's illegitimate they're not married yeah that's right that doesn't worry columbus at all oh he's as devoted to fernando as he is to diego and due course will legitimize him yes fernando turns out to be a tremendous man it's a lovely story tom yeah so i just wanted voted Fernando as he is to Diego, and due course will legitimize him. Fernando turns out to be a tremendous man. It's a lovely story, Tom.
他的个人生活中发生了一件重要的事情，那就是他和科尔多瓦的一个女人有一段露水情缘。哦，是的。贝亚特丽丝·恩里克斯（Beatriz Enríquez），他们有一个私生子费尔南多。为了公平起见，汤姆，他的妻子当时已经去世了。是的，是的。但是他是个私生子，他们没有结婚。是的，没错。这可一点也不困扰哥伦布。哦，他对费尔南多的爱不亚于对迭戈的爱，并且日后会让他合法化。是的，费尔南多后来成了一个了不起的人。这是一个温馨的故事，汤姆。是的。所以我只是想——因为费尔南多对他父亲的记述在塑造哥伦布的神话中非常重要。你听过那些钟声吗，费尔南多？还是你听到了钟声，费尔南多？那首歌是怎么唱的？你听到了钟声吗，费尔南多？那晚空气中弥漫着某种东西。那晚空气中弥漫着某种东西。
Yeah. So I just wanted that because Fernando's reports about his father are kind of very important in creating the myth of Columbus. Have you heard the bells, Fernando? Or do you hear the bells, Fernando? How does it go? Do you hear the bells, Fernando? There was something in the air that night. There was something in the air that night.
好吧，当哥伦布出现时，贝亚特丽丝大概就是这么说的。于是他回到了葡萄牙。葡萄牙人绝对不感兴趣，因为此时巴托洛梅乌·迪亚士已经从非洲绕过好望角回来了。所以在那个时候，葡萄牙人只会想：我们凭什么要在你这个疯狂的计划上花一分钱？因此，哥伦布拖着疲惫的步伐回到了拉拉维达修道院。正是在这个时候，我们开始对他有了一些了解，我们现在有了更多关于他的文献记录。所以他快40岁了——我的意思是，我正要说他正值盛年，但盛年至少有一部分已经在他这个年纪离他远去了，你知道的，时间
Well, that's probably what Beatri said when Columbus showed up. So he goes back to Portugal. Portuguese are definitely not interested because now Bartholomew Diaz has come back from rounding the Cape of Good Hope in Africa. So at that point, the Portuguese are just like, why would we spend any money at all on your mad scheme? Back Columbus trudges therefore to the monastery La Rabida it's about this point that we start to get a sense of him we're getting more documentary reports of him now so he's almost 40 I mean he's I was about to say he's in the prime of life but some of the prime of life at least has passed him by at this point you know time
对他的确至关重要，因为去探险之类的是年轻人的游戏。他很焦虑，但同时他也把时间利用得很充实，因为在他不断往返、在卡斯蒂利亚宫廷闲逛的这段时间里，他结识了许多权贵，尤其是热那亚人。他显然在设法融入他们，因为那是他的同胞。他们会对他说：“如果你真的为这个想法拉到了赞助，我们会出资的。我们会给你一些……”所以他一直在利用这些网络。他遇到了一个非常重要的人，他是阿拉贡王国的财政官员。
probably is of the essence for him, because going on explorations and things is a little bit of a young man's game. He's anxious, but he's also, he is spending the time profitably, because all the time he's going back and forth, and all the time he's hanging around the Castilian court, he's meeting powerful people, particularly Genoese people. And he's sort of getting in with them, obviously, because they're his fellow countrymen. And they are sort of saying, well, if you ever do get backing for this idea, we'll put in some money. We'll give you some, you know. So he's exploiting those networks. He meets one person who's very important, who's a treasury official from the crown of Aragon.
那是斐迪南的王国，名叫路易斯·德·圣安赫尔（Luis de Sant'ángel）。他对他说：“如果你能得到君主的批准，我会为这个项目投入大量资金。这听起来是个绝妙的计划。”他实际上帮哥伦布梳理了——他为他做了推介。他做好了财务预算。电子表格。电子表格，完全没错。幻灯片演示。
That's Ferdinand's kingdom, called Luis de Sant'Angelo. And he says, well, if you ever get the permission of the monarchs, I'll put in lots of money to this. This sounds like a great scheme. And he actually works out Columbus's kind of – he does the pitch for him. He does the finances. The spreadsheets. The spreadsheets, exactly. The PowerPoint presentation.
到1491年末，哥伦布已经有点想要放弃了，他觉得——你知道的，他们永远不会给我开绿灯。与此同时，他的兄弟一直在法国和英国活动，对吧？没错，是的，试图从那里获得支持。所以这是一个相当有趣的——我不认为英国人会理睬这个。关于法国是否能做到这一点，这是一个有趣的问题，因为法国是欧洲的超级大国，或许是西班牙之外最可行的替代方案。西班牙做这件事最可行的替代方案，我猜是葡萄牙。
Columbus, by about late 1491, he's kind of close to giving up, and he thinks this is you know they're never going to give me the go-ahead and meanwhile his brother has been in france and england hasn't he that's right yeah get support from so it's quite an interesting i don't think england are ever going to do it it's an interesting question about whether france could have done it because france is the great power in europe that perhaps the alternatives to spain doing it the most plausible alternative to Spain doing it, I suppose, is Portugal.
但葡萄牙人绝不会这么做，因为他们向东的开拓太成功了。所以我想法国是一个可行的替代方案。让西班牙和葡萄牙成为显而易见投资者的原因在于，他们可以利用自己的大西洋岛屿——加那利群岛、亚速尔群岛、马德拉群岛——作为中转站。至于英国，你知道的，你只是从布里斯托尔扬帆出海，进入这种非常灰暗、暴风雨肆虐的季节，而且无处可停。好吧，还有格陵兰岛，如果他们当时已经到达了纽芬兰，那么，你知道的，整段历史的走向可能会完全不同。历史的重心将聚焦于北美，而不是加勒比海和南部。无论如何，我们并不是在这里做历史反事实推演。
But the Portuguese are never going to do it because their eastern ventures are so successful. So I suppose France is a plausible alternative. What makes Spain and Portugal obvious kind of investors is that they can use their Atlantic Islands, the Canary Islands, the Azores, Madeira, as kind of transit points. England, you know, you're just sailing out from Bristol into this kind of very grey, stormy season, and there's nowhere to stop. Well, there's Greenland, and then if they have reached Newfoundland, then, you know, maybe the whole course of history would have been different. It would have been focused on North America rather than the Caribbean and the South. Anyway, we're not in the business of counterfactual here.
好吧，我们有时其实也在做。但不管怎样，听着，你是对的。最终发生的事情是，拉拉维达的修道士们说：“听着，最后再去争取一下伊莎贝拉女王吧。”他们此时已经快要征服格拉纳达了。于是他又回去了。1491年秋天，他来到了安达卢西亚一个叫圣菲（Santa Fe）的地方，就在格拉纳达城外。
Well, we kind of sometimes are. But anyway, listen, you're right. What does happen is the monks of La Rabida say, listen, have one last go at Queen Isabella. They've almost conquered Granada now. So back he goes. In the autumn of 1491, he gets to a place called Santa Fe in Andalusia, which is outside Granada.
西班牙人为他们的军队建造了一座非同寻常的军营城镇。他们在80天内建成了这座城。它的形状是一个十字架，体现了那种强烈的宗教狂热。他不得不再次向一个委员会陈述他的方案。你知道的，你可以想像他当时的场景。我想休·托马斯在他的著作《黄金之河》（Rivers of Gold）之一中说过，你可以想像一下这样的场景：哥伦布掏出他在欧洲各地展示过的那些破旧文件。他们再一次说：“好吧，我们会成立一个委员会。”
And the Spanish have built this extraordinary kind of barracks town for their army. They built it in 80 days. It's in the shape of a cross, the kind of intense religiosity. Yet again, he has to make his case to a committee. You know, you can imagine him. I think it's Hugh Thomas in one of his books, Rivers of Gold, I think, says, you know, you can basically imagine the scene of Columbus getting out these tattered documents that he's been exhibiting around Europe. Yet again, they say, well, we'll have a committee.
斐迪南和伊莎贝拉两位君主对此做出了非常诡异或者说模棱两可的回应，因为哥伦布在晚年写信给伊莎贝拉时提到，他曾向她陈述了自己的方案，并表示：“用您与印度建立联系后获得的资金，您可以将其用于收复耶路撒冷。”而这，当然就是那位末世帝王命中注定要去做的事情。他说：“两位陛下听了这话都微笑了。”从那以后，人们一直在争论：他们为什么微笑？他们是在嘲笑这种野心的疯狂本质吗？还是因为他们觉得这确实是一种可能？我绝对认为是后者。你是这么认为的？尽管有趣的是，委员会召开了会议，却没有做出决定。与此同时，欧洲历史上发生了一件大事，却完全被1492年发生的其他事情所掩盖：格拉纳达投降了。1月2日。
Well, there's this very kind of eerie or perhaps ambiguous response on the part of the monarchs, Ferdinand and Isabella, because Columbus later in his life, he writes to Isabella and says that, you know, I made my pitch to you. And I said that what you could do with the money that you will get from making contact with India is that you can then spend it on reconquering Jerusalem. Which, of course, is what the last emperor is predestined to do. And he says that your highnesses smiled at this. And there's ever since people have debated, why were they smiling? Were they smiling with mockery at the kind of lunatic nature of this ambition? Or were they smiling because this is a possibility? And I think definitely the latter. You think so? Although the funny thing is, so the committee meets and they don't come to a decision. In the meantime, one of the great landmarks in European history that is then completely overshadowed by what else happens in 1492, Granada surrenders. 2nd of January.
而哥伦布当时就在那里。因此哥伦布在后来的信件中写道：“我看到陛下们骑马进入这座城市。我看到卡斯蒂利亚和阿拉贡的旗帜升起在阿尔罕布拉宫的塔楼之上。”这是一个极其震撼的场景，收复失地运动结束了。伊斯兰教已经被驱逐——好吧，我的意思是，伊斯兰教的势力被驱逐了，因为当地显然还有很多穆斯林，但伊斯兰教的政治势力已经被驱逐出了伊比利亚半岛。这个非凡的时刻过后，委员会做出了决定。他们说：“又来了，你拿出的还是那些老掉牙的破地图。”答案依然是“不”。哥伦布骑着马离开了，他大概是要去法国。
And Columbus is there. So Columbus says later on in one of his letters, he says, I saw your majesties ride into the city. I saw the flags of Castile and Aragon raised above the towers of the Alhambra. This incredibly resonant scene, the Reconquista is finished. Islam has been driven. Well, I mean, the power of Islam, not because there are obviously a lot of Muslims, but the power of Islam has been driven out of the Iberian Peninsula. This extraordinary moment, and then the committee makes their decision. And they say, yet again, you brought out the same
骑着一头骡子，对吗？骑着一头骡子，没错。他走出了离城五英里远的一个叫皮诺斯（Pinos）的地方。这是一个非常具有好莱坞色彩的时刻。一个信使追上了他，对他说：“女王改变主意了。你快回去吧。”现在，发生的事情是，我刚才提到那个路易斯·德·圣安赫尔——来自阿拉贡的那个财政官——曾对君主们说：“你知道吗？这不是一件很大的投资。最糟糕的是，万一葡萄牙人……格拉纳达的战争让他们资金短缺，而圣安赫尔实际上说：‘我来筹钱，别担心。我们已经有一大堆投资者随时准备出手了。’”哥伦布与君主们会面了。他们为什么要这么做？他们为什么会——他们需要现金，因为他们在格拉纳达战争中花了太多钱；但同时这也是个悖论：他们征服了格拉纳达，却因此变得更穷了，
tired old maps. The answer is still no. And Columbus rides off and he's probably going to France. On a mule, is that right? On a mule, that's right. And he gets five miles out of the city to a place called Pinos. It's this very Hollywood moment. A messenger catches up with him and says, the queen has changed her mind. Back you come. Now, what has happened is that that guy I mentioned, Louis de Saint-Ankel, the guy from Aragon, the treasurer, he has spoken to the monarchs and he has said, do you know what? It's not a very big investment. And the worst thing is, what if the Portuguese do do the war in granada they are short of money and santangar actually says i'll find the money don't worry we've got a whole load of investors ready to go columbus meets up with the monarchs why do they do it why have they you know they need the cash because they've spent so much money on the war in granada but also also this is the paradox that they've conquered granada but they're poorer because of
因为现在他们失去了来自穆斯林非洲的贡赋。完全正确。他们有你提到的那种十字军东征的情结。还有一个同样有趣的因素。他们需要资金的另一个原因是，他们决定驱逐犹太人。所以他们此时已经决定这就是他们要做的事。他们还没有颁布法令，但已经做出了决定。他们在1492年的头几个月里决定，他们将迫使西班牙的犹太人口改信基督教或离开。而西班牙的犹太人口中有很多商人、
it because now they get the tribute that's coming from Muslim Africa. Exactly right. They've got that crusading thing that you mentioned. There's one other element which is so interesting. Another reason they need money is they have decided to kick out the Jews. So they've already decided at this point that this is what they're going to do. They haven't published the decree, but they have decided. They decide in the first couple of months of 1492 that they will force the Jewish population of Spain to convert to Christianity or leave. And the Jewish population of Spain, there are lots of merchants, there are traders,
手工业者、金融家、医生等等，这些都是对他们王国的财政成功至关重要富裕人群。随着他们的离开——因为其中许多人显然会离开——斐迪南和伊莎贝拉对现金的渴望比以往任何时候都更加迫切。如果奇迹发生，哥伦布是对的，他真的能到达亚洲，那就再好不过了。于是4月17日，他们在格拉纳达城外的圣菲重新集会。他们说：“好吧，你可以成为海洋大督办，这将是世袭的。你可以成为总督和总督长。你可以成为海洋海军大督办，这将是世袭的。你可以成为总督和总督长，你可以成为‘唐’（Don），你有权获得你发现的一切财富的十分之一。
there are artisans, financiers, doctors, and so on, well-off people who are important to the financial success of their kingdom. So with them gone, because a lot of them obviously will go, the need for Ferdinand and Isabella to get their hands on some cash is more important than ever. And if by some miracle Columbus is right and he can get to Asia, so much the better. So 17th of April, they reconvene in Santa Fe outside the walls of Granada. And they say, fine, you can be the Admiral of the Ocean Sea, it will be hereditary. You can be Viceroy and Governor General. You can be the admiral of the ocean sea it will be hereditary you can be vice governor general you can be don you can have a right to a tenth of everything you discover
当你到达那里时，你可以掌管司法，审理所有的诉讼以及诸如此类的事情。”这些东西哥伦布看得极其重。我的意思是，在某种程度上，这就是他梦寐以求的。而且这笔投资实际上并没有那么巨大。因为只有三艘船，对吧？那是三艘船。费用将是200万马拉维迪（maravedis，当时的一种货币）。一个很好的对比是，年轻的凯瑟琳公主（阿拉贡的凯瑟琳）与英国亚瑟·都铎王子结婚的花费是6000万。
and when you get there you can be in charge of justice and you can hear all the suits and all this sort of thing these things columbus takes enormously seriously i mean to some extent that's what he's after and the investment actually is not that massive an investment. Because it's only three ships, right? It's three ships. It's going to be 2 million madrevedis, which is the currency. A lovely comparison is that the cost of the wedding of the young Catherine of Aragon to Prince Arthur Tudor in England is 60 million.
所以与这笔花费相比，这根本不算什么。哪笔投资更好呢？是的。从阿拉贡的凯瑟琳的角度来看，我想是的。是的，这说得非常对这里面总是有一种紧张感，因为并不是很清楚——没有人确切规定哥伦布到底要做什么：他是打算定居？还是像葡萄牙人那样建立贸易据点？他们在交易中并没有明说——去找日本，去找中国。这非常模糊。
So this is nothing compared with how much. Which is the better investment there? Yeah. From Catherine of Aragon's point of view, I think. Yes, that's a very good point. So interestingly, there is always a sort of tension in this because it's not entirely clear what no one sets down exactly what Columbus isus is going to do is he going to settle is he going to establish trading posts like the portuguese do they don't say in the sort of deal find japan find china it's very vague yeah deep down a lot of their advisors think it's completely unrealistic and for columbus as it's clear because he writes it again and again, what actually matters is all there preeminently, even more than his desire to find gold for Ferdinand to conquer Jerusalem or any of that kind of stuff.
但在内心深处，他们的许多顾问认为这完全是不切实际的。而对于哥伦布来说，正如显而易见的那样，因为他一遍又一遍地书写，真正重要的事情是至高无上的，甚至超过了他为斐迪南征服耶路撒冷寻找黄金的渴望，或是任何此类事情。他去那里是因为他想要头衔。他想在世界的舞台上崭露头角。他想要确立自己的地位。他再也不想让别人盯着他看了。
He's going there because he wants titles. He wants to cut a dash on the stage of the world. He wants to be established. He doesn't want people staring at him anymore. Yeah, he wants to return and people to say, there is an immensely rich and important man, the Admiral of the Ocean Sea, the Viceroy, Don Cristóbal Colombo, or whatever they would call him, Cristóbal Colombo. Exactly.
是的，他想要凯旋而归，让人们惊叹：那是一个极其富有和重要的人物，海洋大督办、总督、“堂”克里斯托弗·哥伦布阁下，或者无论他们怎么称呼他——克里斯托瓦尔·科隆。完全正确。
He wants to be the big man, and that's what he's going for. He is a prickly, pious, intense, serious man. But finally, after all of this faffing around, he has the permission he needs. And he can now get on with planning this extraordinary voyage. Okay. Let's end with a letter that Columbus in late years wrote to Isabella and Ferdinand. Your Highness has commanded me that with a sufficient fleet, I should go to the said parts of India. And for this accorded me great rewards and ennobled
他想成为大人物，而这正是他所追求的。他是一个敏感、虔诚、狂热且严肃的人。但最终，在经历了这一切折腾之后，他得到了他需要的许可。他现在可以继续筹划这趟非凡的航行了。好了。让我们以哥伦布在晚年写给伊莎贝拉和斐迪南的一封信来结束这一段：“陛下曾命令我率领一支充足的舰队前往上述印度地区，并为此赐予我极大的奖赏和封号，
me so that from that time henceforth, I might style myself Don, so sir, and be high admiral of the ocean sea and viceroy and perpetual governor of the islands and continent which I should discover, and that my elder son should succeed to the same position and so on from generation to generation forever and the tension there between going there to India which they already know and then talking about islands and continents which he should discover I mean that is a tension that will shadow him over the course of the four voyages that are to follow and the whole of his life. Yeah. Now, if you are interested in those voyages, in all three of these episodes to come, because Tom, this is a pretty mighty series, isn't it? It's a bit like Columbus's own voyages. Those three episodes are available now for members of
使我自那时起可以自称为‘堂’（Don），即大人，并成为海洋的大督办、以及我所发现的岛屿和大陆的总督与永久总督，我的长子亦将继承同等职位，如此代代相传，直至永远。”在那里，去往他们已知印度的意图，与谈论他将要发现的岛屿和大陆之间存在着一种紧张关系——我的意思是，这种紧张关系将笼罩他随后的四次航行以及他的一生。好了，如果你对那些航行感兴趣，对接下来所有的三集节目感兴趣——因为汤姆，这是一个相当庞大的系列，不是吗？这有点像哥伦布自己的航行。那三集节目现在已经面向
the Rest Is History Club. If you're not a member of the Rest Is History Club and you would like to become a member, you can subscribe very easily on Apple Podcasts. So you just go to the Rest Is History feed and you click try free. And that entitles you to a month long free trial of the Rest Is History Club. Now you can also sign up at restishistorypod.com, but if you prefer to do the trial, just do the trial. And if for some peculiar and sinister reason you are not enticed to become a member of our fantastic crew, well, God have mercy on your soul. Yeah. Stay in Spain. All right. On that bombs that bomb show adios bye-bye
《历史的沉淀》俱乐部（The Rest Is History Club）的会员开放了。如果你还不是《历史的沉淀》俱乐部会员并且想加入，你可以非常轻松地在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）上订阅。你只需进入《历史的沉淀》订阅源并点击“免费试用”。这就能让你获得一个月的《历史的沉淀》俱乐部免费试用期。当然，你也可以在 restishistorypod.com 注册，但如果你倾向于试用，直接去试用就好了。如果出于某些诡异而阴暗的原因，你没有被吸引成为我们这支梦幻船队的一员，那么，愿上帝怜悯你的灵魂吧。是的，留在西班牙吧。好吧。伴随着那个重磅炸弹般的言论，再见，拜拜。
thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at restishistorypod.com that's restishistorypod.com I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
感谢收听《历史的沉淀》。如需收听独家加更节目、抢先体验无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册，网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐至上》，这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和娱乐圈八卦的固定栏目，在我们的问答环节中，我们为娱乐行业揭开神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票的福利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。